The joe rogan experience,
but there's something creepy about mayor set male feminists and that's why I
wanted you to pull up that video.
Brian and I tweeted this yesterday,
it's by these guys that called themselves the conscious men.
Okay?
And it is like an an apology.
And I like a manifesto.
I'll,
I'll read the description.
Gonna be half of men or apology to women,
apology to women and on behalf of men to women because they are conscious and
they were trying to get in touch with their feminine femininity.
They are.
I've never seen a bigger group of w w look like date rapists and creeps and,
and just annoying fucking weak ass bitches.
Have you been to comicon?
No,
I haven't.
Okay.
Is it different?
Is it worse?
Watch this though.
You must do this.
You have to see this for,
for,
for folks living,
living.
Don't listen to me no matter what I say.
Listen,
even if you agree with me,
I'm an idiot.
Listen,
listen to this band before you today as men committed to becoming more conscious
from every way we feel.
Deep love,
great respect,
and a growing.
By the way,
the man talking.
His name is gay Hendricks.
We also feel deep sorrow about the destructive actions of the unconscious
masculine in the past and present.
We want to apologize and make amends for those actions today so that we can move
forward together into a new era of the pink spoon.
What is,
you know what that has?
It's a foundation.
They're calm,
they're enlightened.
Why?
Listen to the music and then she listens to me in you in order of life.
I know that we all have access to the full spectrum of these energies.
If you see this guy,
you realize how fucking creepy this sounds like your wellness.
There's gotta be a firewall for skittles commodities.
I admit it.
I can only think about Kevin ribbon or living in month.
I can work with mass with the music I play with it.
Look at these.
I know that in order to truly honor you as a multidimensional,
a woman and Lust and fully present and oh and the gifts,
I bought drugs from him absolutely at this guy rapist and treat each other in a
conscious way.
Clearly leaders,
he's got an ankle bracelet
and by worshiping that affinity expressed with the masculine and feminine
energies,
that Guy's full of shit.
That guy's just looking for a little smile at the end has often been
unconscious.
I feel so these all look like people that went to a camp to pray the gay away
could,
I mean
this guy's reformed.
He's totally into pussy now.
Yeah,
from wicker man.
It's a woman burning at the stake just showing a woman,
women burning at the cross.
Here's what you don't understand.
What the fuck.
Oh that that bring you.
The crossing was explained,
relegated you to subservient chores,
forced you have to hide your faces and even cut off your organs of sexual
pleasure that are
extreme that I'm aware of.
The forces of the unconscious masculine psyche powered by
masculine psyche.
Many of the men who have a,
this guy's mashing like psyche and its mouth among the living.
Many men may not be able to apologize because they remain shock.
Holden in a prison of anger,
fear and you a shitty poet,
dude,
half of my gender,
Josh to you,
don't you say shit.
When we were angry,
scared glip,
it destructive forces in our psyche and I choose to no longer contribute to
those forces.
I just noticed room smells like it's wooden paneled and somebody tears in.
She smells like faggotry.
It's not poker player guide.
Of course.
I think knowledge is this the most ridiculous shit ever.
A thousand years I've been mainly founded by this guy who propagated by men.
We've often acted as if he got Brody,
Stevens,
God and the spiritual life and all.
You have visits end with an invite.
This has got,
but in his right to a Trump circle there's this big contest and he just got done
selling meth,
inclusive spirituality
to honoring the state away to do the hard limb.
I honor your deep connection to the earth as man.
Right,
so I hadn't any.
Now is that the point?
All of these guys,
it just crawled back into my stomach.
All you guys are willing to roofie you domination.
Mistakenly believed that expansion who protect us from encroachment and in the
process we violated the sanctity of the years.
I can't even watch it.
Look,
I understand that they have good intentions and I'm sure they're not really
rapists,
but you got to understand folks,
you're all what we would classify as weak ass bitches and that's why you're
feeling this way and that's why you're feeling like you need to go out and save
the world and make these women look.
Women are going to be fine.
Yeah,
that would be nice to women.
Absolutely.
Other than making youtube,
they're trying to look cool.
They're trying to,
they're trying to get really broken women to like them.
You know the kind of women that look,
they can't attract them.
They're not interesting.
They're probably not successful.
They're not intelligent,
they're not swole,
they're not sexually attractive.
They probably have nothing going on.
No one's cost puts them in a diaper in a cage and whip them.
I don't even think of that.
That would be too exciting.
They have less than that and they,
I think to have that,
I think that pay for that out the nose.
I think you just fucking speculating at this point.
Aren't we all over the world here?
Right?
Let's speculate away.
But what they are is weekends pitches and we don't need that.
We'll do those men need is stakes and squats and bootcamp and,
and,
and someone who gets them a fucking interest,
get whatever the fuck it is,
man.
So let's make an apology video on behalf of men for them.
Should be,
that's what it should be.
We should dear we gas tax of the world,
dear women,
dear women who have been,
you know,
compromise by these knuckleheads and try to pretend that men aren't men and
women aren't women and there's some sort of a hybrid that you can be,
well,
you can appeal to the women and embrace your feminine energy food.
I'm sorry you've had a crate and barrel magazine Humping Douche bag and walk
over your whole life.
But I promise I will waltz into your bedroom,
choke you during climax and probably spent in your mouth.
If you can't gorilla fucker check,
you better know some poetry and that's the reality.
You better know how to write some shit down and make it rom.
You better know what kind of flowers she likes.
You better be good at massages and if you're lucky,
Sheila,
and should probably barely be wet sand.
She's not really into the dude cook our salmon,
but her trainer might fuck this shit out of her.
I'll tell you that her train of my fucker in a parking lot,
man,
he might just whip out his fucking hog in a parking lot.